hello hello good morning I am very
excited to be back on this stage two
years ago we came here and we debuted
the very first clip from The Avengers
has anyone seen the rest of the film The
Avengers oh good good we had a movie
called Iron Man 3 that came out did
anyone see Iron Man 3 this summer that
was the first in our phase 2 the next
one comes out in a mere three months for
the dark world
Tom Hiddleston
I didn't bring the costume but I did
bring some friends of mine ladies and
gentlemen please give a very very warm
welcome to Natalie Portman
it's ladies denim it's also my great
pleasure to introduce someone otherwise
known as Odin the all-father Anthony
Hopkins
so as we continue our journey through
Marvel's phase to the next film up is in
April of 2014
Captain America the Winter Soldier
the Winter Soldier himself Sebastian
Stan
anthony mackie
my son
and Chris Evans
I'm gonna tell you a really funny story
this is actually absolutely true I was I
just got back to town I was doing press
overseas I got back and my buddy's like
hey you know cuz I always bring them
with me when I go to Disneyland and
someone hit me up and was like oh we
should we should do Disneyland I was
like great you know what we should do it
this Saturday and I called my whole team
and I said can we do a Disneyland trip
and they said well before or after do
you 23 wear a hat we're a happy
Disneyland of course Disneyland I live
for Disney everything did all the time
it's journeying further into 2014 four
months after the Winter Soldier we're
debuting something new something totally
new something brand-new called guardians
of the galaxy Gardens the galaxy is an
excellent comic book with excellent
characters but it is not particularly
well known and that excites us to debut
something brand new the director and
co-writer that film is James Gunn who is
doing an amazing job with his cast of
Chris Pratt Zoe Saldana Dave Bautista
leap ace Michael Rooker Karen Gillan
Djimon Honsou and john c reilly Benicio
del Toro and Glenn Close it's an
incredible ensemble - their father
Banas esse T is a simple baños esse T
forget about your worries and your
strife
necessities Oh mother nature's recipes
will bring the bare necessities of life